il est parfois difficile de se
remobiliser sur le championnat après un
exploit retentissant en coupe de france
mais l'équipe des moins de 19 ans de
l'usb en cours n'est pas tombé dans le
piège trappistes pourtant les guyancourt
toit se font surprendre sur cette erreur
défensive de l'axé central
le gardien reste impuissant sur cette
enroulée du gauche en pleine lucarne
sans affolement les verts remettent le
pied sur le ballon en fin de première
période ils obtiennent un coup franc à
l'entrée de la surface de réparation
trappistes fanel saint-félix s'en charge
les jeunes de l'ès guyancourt s'impose
finalement 2 buts à 1
il continue de profiter de la dynamique
de coupe et consolident leur place de
leader avec quatre points d'avancé sur
le second le mesnil saint denis trappe
reste sixième